Sue smart to talk to regular people.
Boom.
Powerful big wave surfer.
How are you buddy?
I'm great.
We just got back from playing little techno hunt.
We did man.
Ah,
greatest thing of all time,
right?
I was just saying,
I don't care what the price is.
It's worth it.
It's a bargain at twice the price or whatever it is.
Yeah.
Where people don't know what it is.
It's this game that it's simulates bow hunting.
So what it is is,
is a giant screen that's made out of Kevlar and then uh,
it's got us like a projector projects,
HD images of elk and deer.
You could set it up for a bunch of different animals,
but elk and deer walk across the screen and you shoot at him and it's like the
perfect,
there's a show,
a little video of Shane Dan earlier.
It's a really cool man.
It's a perfect practice for bow hunting because one of the things about bow
hunting is a,
you get nervous and the more you could do something like this,
we just shot a perfect shot.
The more you could do that over and over and over again,
the more it becomes ingrained in your,
your,
your nervous system,
grained in your muscles,
ingrained in your memory,
and then it becomes natural.
Yeah.
It's awesome.
Yeah,
it's pretty dope.
We're going to make this podcast about 15 minutes long and go back and shit.
So
yeah,
that's what we were actually talking about.
Cutting off the podcast.
Short this for that.
So tell me about this movie,
man.
Yeah,
so I'm in La for the premiere,
the HBO Premiere of the Momentum Generation.
It's a,
it's a,
uh,
it's a sports documentary that Hbo and Robert Redford did.
So it's cool,
man.
It's really cool.
It's,
um,
it's a story about my friends and I,
we,
you know,
we all grew up a competitive surfers and in high school we all sort of met each
other through,
through competitions competing.
So this tells a story of how we,
basically,
how we met,
how we grew up,
um,
and how we became friends and family.
Basically like traveling around the world,
you know,
together as basically like little kids with no with no chaperones on,
on tour around the world.
So crazy.
It's a wild story.
And pull this up to like keep this like a fist away.
How old were you when you first started surfing a s started surfing on a standup
surfboard when I was five.
And when did you start traveling serve?
Yeah,
when I was 12 I went to England for the world amateur championships.
Wow.
So I was on the Hawaii Team doing this traveling surfing thing most of your
life.
Yeah.
Wow.
It's crazy.
That is nuts man.
I've been,
I've been putting my surfboards in a board bag and you know,
walking out the door with my passport since I was 12 and going to so many
different destinations around the world,
literally just for surfing.
Why do nuts does,
is such a crazy way to grow up.
And that's a cool thing about the film is all of us had that in common.
And it's,
it's crazy the way the story set up too because there's so many things in it
that I didn't really realize were happening at the time.
Like,
like I came from,
I came from a broken family,
alcoholic father,
you know,
kind of a radical,
um,
situation at home.
And then like a lot of us had like broken families.
A lot of us had that in common.
So we sort of have like this weird fucked up family dynamic in common.
So we all became sort of like our own family on the road.
So we were competing for a world title.
We're all competing and going around the world all the time,
staying together.
So we became best friends like this nucleus of surfers and we all just became
ultra clothes.
And then when things get got really serious with a surfing competition and there
was a lot on the line with sponsors and money and big brands coming in,
the shit hit the fan.
And then we started like breaking up.
It got too serious.
It was almost like a band who just couldn't stand each other anymore or things
got too radical or girls got in the way or money got in the way and so there was
like this kind of like breaking up element,
you know,
throughout our group.
Wow.
I would imagine when you're living like that,
those people must be so valuable for you though.
People that can understand your way of life because it's their way of life too.
Cause like two to a regular person who commutes every day and goes to an office
and comes home.
Like your life is alien.
Yeah,
it is.
I still get like,
I still get uncomfortable when people ask me what I do for a living.
You know,
like I'll,
I'll like,
I'll be in like a normal random setting and some of you that,
hell yeah,
what do you do for a living?
And I'm like,
no,
do not ask me that because nobody understands.
You know?
It's like,
what do you tell them?
I tell them the truth,
but it's,
I just tell,
I always tell him like it's,
it's really hard to explain,
but I surf for a living and do,
what the fuck is that?
Yeah.
Did they go,
how does that work?
How do you paid?
Yes.
All the time.
And I just got to have no idea.
Well you don't really compete any longer right now.
Not at all.
Right.
Big Waves.
I do all ride big waves.
That's my focus.
And I also write all kinds of waves.
I surf every day and you know,
the waves don't get big that often.
Right.
When the waves are biggest,
I'm on it.
Yeah.
For a person that like is just meeting you for the first time and doesn't
understand surfing and it's trying to wrap their head around making a living,
riding the waves of the ocean.
What's like how or why,
but wait a minute.
No,
I went to accounting school and I,
and I don't have,
there's not like a,
there's nothing,
I mean there's,
there's not like another category I can really point to,
to,
to make the point go quicker to,
there's not like,
um,
you know,
it's like there's basketball players and football players and all of them are
like scoring goals and getting these brand endorsements from that,
from competition element.
So because I'm a free surfer who doesn't compete at all,
it's just,
it's hard to wrap your head around,
but basically harder.
Yeah.
Basically.
I,
you know,
uh,
I have a large surfing profile and so like I worked with a lot of brands and
that's just the kind of,
the way it works.
It just sponsors.
Yeah.
Now this movie,
this documentary,
did they have footage of you guys from when you were really young?
Oh,
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
they do.
Is that weird watching that stuff?
Yeah,
very weird because we're all in our forties now.
We all got kids and for most of us,
except for Kelly,
Kelly is still going.
You 40.
Yeah,
46 years old.
I,
I saw him on your show the other day.
It was pretty classic,
but so,
so he's like a focal point in the film.
He's,
he's part of the momentum generation and um,
and so he,
there is incredible footage of him when he's,
you know,
nine years old or 10 years old and he's in Florida,
like a little rat,
like a little sunburn rat.
And it's neat,
you know,
I mean,
I mean we all had that in common.
That's sweet.
We all grew up in,
in different places and then we all fell in love with surfing,
you know,
separately.
And then we all just became super tight.
So.
Wow.
It was a great,
it's,
it's great.
And then now we're all like best friends again because there's no,
there's no points on a line or a world title on the line or like brands getting
in the way or girls getting in the way.
We're all,
we're all,
you know.
Yeah.
We're finally growing up.
That,
I mean,
that had to be strange though to be so tight and then everything sort of get
bottleneck by the pressure.
Yeah.
And you think serving,
how much pressure could there be?
But you know,
we're all trying to make a living,
right?
It's like,
yeah,
you know,
that was our dream to like surf as much as possible and see the world.
And that's the only way you could do it for us.
Whenever there's competition,
there's gotta be massive amounts of pressure.
Whenever there's someone trying to achieve something or someone trying to rise
to the top of a profession and you're surrounded by a bunch of you,
but you also must have pushed each other too.
And it must have been beneficial to have people like you around as well.
I think it's,
it's part of,
okay.
It's just,
you know,
I think it's like part of our,
our like human DNA to,
you know,
to be naturally competitive.
So I think especially men,
I think we feel like we have something approved,
you know,
like where are we stand,
like compare to the other guys.
What,
whether it was like in the cave man days or,
or like the,
you know,
the,
the first hunters where it was there for sure they were there.
They were competitive to see you could bring to home,
meet for the,
for the tribe.
And then it just kept going from there.
And,
and,
and now we,
we,
we compete with whatever we're into.
And you know,
for us with surfing we came hyper competitive and especially me,
like from the time I was like maybe 16 or 17 until the time I was like my mid
twenties I was like super competitive where I want to rip people's heads off my
heat.
Like I would like visualize horrible,
horrible things happening to them while I was competing against them.
Like what?
And it's fine.
It's so crazy how that's gone.
100% gone from my,
my being now,
I can't even imagine doing that.
I'm like the most relaxed,
non competitive person.
I,
I have no competitiveness left in my body.
Well I've only known you for what,
four years or something like that in those years I could not imagine you having
evil thoughts towards someone who seems so chill.
I was a shit talker.
Where are you really?
Yeah.
I,
I remember I was surfing against this Guy Damien Hardman and,
and he was like an Australian world champion and he was like a older generation.
We were from the young,
like new school generation.
We are coming up and there's these established guys who didn't want to,
you know,
like be dethroned and there was this Guy Damien Hardman who was a bad ass
competitive surfer,
but he was a very like tactician conservative.
You'd never fall.
He seem like a nerd to me.
You know what I mean?
I was like this rock kid from Hawaii and this guy was like so presentable and
professional and I just like resented it and I was in a heat with him and he got
priority,
which means that he had first right of wave and I just needed a tiny little
score to win.
And he basically sat on me,
which means he uses it.
He used his priority to chase me around the lineup and sit on me and keep me
from cutting a wave and let the time run out.
And the whole time I was like,
you surf like a girl,
you,
you sort of feel like a little bitch.
Like all this like totally shit talking him.
And did it work?
Did he get you?
He got me because he wrote the Dynamo.
Aye.
Basically cracked and started like getting emotional and he loved it.
He,
man,
I got this guy beat.
He started to shit talk me.
He loved that.
I any,
any uh,
he actually came up to me later and he goes,
I love it that you're that passionate.
I love it that you got that site and that emotional where you just started like
trying to like insult me.
He's like,
that's my goal when I'm in heats with people is to get them to that point.